all right Jennifer
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally I grew up in Colorado I
graduated from a tiny little high school
with 79 people in my graduating class
tell me about your family
you know normal family I guess two
brothers Mom Dad
I joined the military at 17 to kind of
just get away from the small town and
see what I could make of myself
joined the military and
how long was that five years five years
yeah
that was a good experience
yeah it's like the best of times worst
times right
how would you describe your childhood in
general
it was rough
no like Monies
money was hard money was tight
um education and short supply you know
so
it's kind of hard Scrabble I guess you'd
say
what was your relationship like with
your mom and dad
my mom she's she's a good person she's
um
she always encouraged me whatever I
wanted to do you know like oh you could
be an astronaut like
Mom I'm not that smart I couldn't have
been an astronaut but uh
yeah she was good and
my dad's just you know
he is who he is
which is what
which is not worthy of mentioned
honestly
and then after the military
for the military I got married right out
right out of the military and um
I had a lot of stuff going on and it was
like
I don't know just uh I got into acting
as like a way of dealing with the stuff
I was going through and it was great
because you could either go to the VA
and the VA would be like
you know what's wrong with you or you
could go to an audition and they'd be
like
wow your mental illness is so vulnerable
like you're so vulnerable we applaud
this and so I was like wow I could get
paid to
like be Wackadoo or I could just go to
the VA and be mocked
so
I chose the more
interesting option he became an actor
yeah it's worked out pretty well yeah
you're in the right town for it now yeah
I am it's worked out
in your marriage yeah you're still
married yeah
[Music]
and you've been through some health
issues
yeah tell me about that
so
I was here in California and uh
I mean everything was shut down due to
covet in 2020.
and my hair started falling out and I
just wasn't feeling well and
I called my doctor's office and they're
like you know we're really not seeing
people unless it's cancer patients we're
going to kind of wait till kova dies
down and I was like yo yeah like I
totally get that so
I waited and didn't get any better
and we ended up moving to where
it's not important but
I went into the doctor because the
covered restriction weren't as weren't
as bad outside of LA County
and they're like yeah your white blood
cell count is is elevated like let's see
what's going on
so I went in and
had some tests done I couldn't figure
anything out and then I went in to have
a full body scan being a redhead with
green eyes and skin like a ghost
wouldn't have a full body scan and there
was a spot on my foot and it was like I
don't know it just looked like a freckle
like
started itching I thought okay maybe
mosquitoes Love Me Maybe it's that
and he said what's going on there I said
I don't know and he felt it and there
was a nodule underneath it and he said I
don't know what that is let's go ahead
and take it so they biopsied it and it
didn't look like anything on a poster
right like melanoma was like all these
like skin growths where you're like
clearly that's cancer
I didn't know and uh he called me in
December 21st 2020 and as soon as I
picked up the phone and it was his voice
I knew and I said okay what do we do and
he said we'll just cut it out it'll be
fine it probably didn't spread
so I talked to the surgeon and the
surgeon said no no no no no there's a
three percent chance it's right
and I got off the phone and I was like I
don't have a good feeling about this my
husband said ah you're just being you
know
it's fine three percent chance
went in for surgery
they operated on my foot
took skin from my leg to close it back
up took lymph nodes out of my groin
and uh
on the ninth day
pathology was supposed to come back in
seven
and on the ninth day he called at 7 pm
and uh yeah I knew
[Music]
and I remember I said to him I said
you said there was a three percent
chance of it spreading and he said I'm
sorry you're my three percenter
so
stage three
um
it was the most fit I've been in my
entire life
four kids
been married for 18 years and uh
[Music]
stage three
and I looked perfectly healthy
so
it's a lot
and I and I always thought
if I were to die like if an asteroid
comes tomorrow what can we do right and
I've lived such a great life like you
can't even write the life that I've had
but to Orphan my children
that was hard to even think about that
you know
it was hard and the whole time
I had to
keep it to myself
I couldn't be open about it because
at the time I was on Stranger Things
and I thought if they know they might
try to write me out out of compassion
like oh she has to focus on her health
um
let's you know give her some time off so
she can focus on that but but I didn't
want that I just wanted to to try to be
normal
and uh the show that I host on the CW
you know I I couldn't tell them because
if your host is out
there's a good chance it'll get canceled
and I have a crew and I love my crew and
they have mortgages families so
just had to pretend that I was fine and
I felt so alone
so alone
and I couldn't talk to anybody and uh
I just basically had to fight it on my
own
and then the place that I moved to
um
I didn't have time to meet anybody so my
only friends
were the oncology team
with my oncologist my nurses the
phlebotomist
the way I found
my way around the new town was
based off of the oncology center
my cardiologist all my Specialists and
it was so isolating it was so isolating
um
and I remember when I showed up
to shoot stranger things
it kind of gave me like a
like a double take because I lost so
much weight
and somebody made a comment to me like
are you are you being method
because my character's going to this
really hard time
and I just laughed and I was like no I'm
not being method but they
you know people were concerned
he's terrified to lose my jobs
you know and they're great they're great
they never do it out of anything other
than concern
but it's scary I have children to feed
it's hard because
I was trying to
balance everything and act like
everything was okay and
I couldn't really take off completely
because I needed to work
so it's just isolating and I would go on
set of different things and I would hear
people
you know as as we do we complain about
mundane things the traffic the weather
and I wondered if I'd
be there by Christmas I wondered if I'd
be there for my kids birthdays
and it really
really changed my life
and
you know once you've had one sort of
cancer
you're at elevated risk for secondary
cancer
so it's never really like your
oh I'm in the I'm in the clear
everything's good to go it's more just
I had a second chance how can I make the
best of it
and just stay really really vigilant
and hope I catch it when it comes back
because it will come back
most likely
so it's just a matter of time I guess
you know
so you beat that
the what was in your foot and they said
it spread so
when it was just on my phone it was
stage one and then
by the time they got to it when they
took the lymph nodes out uh
the lymph nodes showed there was cancer
so it had spread quickly and they they
ran tests and I don't have any genetic
markers for it
um melanoma is is common in post-9 11
Veterans
um
if it's on the scalp or the head it's
mainly because of sun exposure in the
desert
other areas it could be because of
chemical absorption all the chemicals
that we're exposed to so
I don't know what it's from there's not
a genetic link there
but I do carry the gene I'm graph
positive which means that basically
kind of grows faster than it normally
would it could spread faster
so I've had to be
just
extra vigilant about it and you know
halfway through treatment I was feeling
okay I was just really run down
but I remember I I went in for a scan
and
I went in for the results and she sits
down the physician's assistant
and she rolls the stool up to me
and I promise you
I wanted to do this and kick the stool
out from under her and run out the door
and uh
she told me that they found something on
my scan in my liver
and I said well
what is it she said I don't know but it
wasn't there three months ago
and so you know I left thinking it was
stage four that was it
and for 12 days
until I had a biopsy a liver biopsy
every morning I woke up thinking
I'm stage four
and I'm gonna die
my kids won't have a mom
and I'm gonna die
so thankfully
that's not what it was Against All Odds
that's not what it was
but I'll never forget
how it made me feel
and how it changed me and how that made
me even more proactive so right after
that
I went and I scheduled a mammogram even
though I wasn't old enough I scheduled I
was 39 and insurance was trying to fight
me
I scheduled a mammogram an upper
endoscopy a colonoscopy I went and saw
my eye doctor because melanoma can show
up in the eye sometime I went to the
dentist and had my gums checked I went
to my OB GYN because sometimes it can
show up and in other regions I checked
my entire body like a hypochondriac
and thankfully everything came back
okay
um and the sad thing is
with this cancer people think oh you can
just cut it out you can't just cut it
out
once it gets into your lymphatic system
it's there
and next it goes into the organs if you
don't catch it
so I just wish that those kind of myths
would be
dispelled and people don't understand
how important it is if you if you see
something on your body you say okay well
I'm just getting older it's it's normal
it could be cancer just waiting and
lurking and by the time you go to the
doctor to get it taken care of your
stage four
and what then
because you didn't want to go to the
doctor and it's prevalent in our society
I'll go later I'll take care of it later
sometimes there's no later
[Music]
I'm really lucky to be alive
[Music]
I told myself I wasn't gonna cry
said I'm going to keep it together
so today you're you're back working and
everything is
uh everything's okay today I'm back
working I have been cancer-free for four
months
I've never wanted a tattoo in my life
never saw the importance of putting
anything on my body that was permanent
but I got this one when I finished
treatment
it's Joshua 1 9.
be strong and courageous do not be
afraid or discouraged for the Lord your
God is with you wherever you go
and I don't know what other people
believe
but I can tell you that God saved my
life
and I would not be on this Earth
without the strength that he provided to
me
and I don't expect people to
believe that if that's not your thing
because it's not
it's my experience and it's what I went
through and I know
so I'm back to work and
looking at things completely different
and embarrassingly enough
you know actors we have to actually
memorize lines and
the treatment did such a number on my
brain
that sometimes it's embarrassing because
you go back on set
and people who don't know think you just
didn't prepare
or you're you know ditzy or whatever and
I just uh
my brain is just not like it was before
and it'll it'll probably get better the
longer I'm out of it but
[ __ ] I'm alive you know all that is
secondary
this must have made some changes in the
way you view your family and
life in general
you know I'm much more
um
I just I don't care what people say or
what people think and I've always kind
of been that way
but I just live by the Mantra of
you know other people's opinion of me is
none of my business they can think what
they want uh
I do literally everything now
I was I was always good at bucket list
stuff because I always thought well why
wait until you're 90 to do something why
be the you know the the guys at Niagara
Falls who are in their Wheelchairs and
they're seeing Niagara Falls in the
retirement home I never wanted to be
that
but since then if there's something I
want to do I just do it I just I do it
and and the world is so different I I'll
look at a tree
and people will see a tree
and I'll see the colors and the shapes
and the texture of the leaves and
maybe something changed in my brain
permanently I don't know
but I see the world like I've never seen
it before
and it's such an incredible gift
and and
part of me
you know being that I was in the
military I understand
Survivor skill right because I I only
lost a few people that I knew when I was
serving
but after you lose so many to pts and
people taking their own lives and
so I get the concept of Survivor skill
there were six of us
who were around my age 38 to 42.
who were diagnosed
within maybe a year of each other that I
knew
and three of them are dead
six
of us and three are dead from the
military or from uh some from the
military most from the military and a
couple people that I knew so four
military two civilian just people I knew
around my age
and three are dead so
there's a part of me that
it's like why why me
an acquaintance of mine
he lost his wife and we were diagnosed
around the same time
I just didn't understand why I'm still
here I'm
eternally grateful but I just didn't
understand why
but with that being said
um
I think one thing that
that we lose when we put too much focus
on why am I here why am I here
I don't know why I'm here and
I don't know if I'll ever know but I
know that I owe it
to the three of my friends who did not
survive
to live the life that they would have
wanted
and that they can't
whatever that is traveling or trying a
new beer or
you know tucking their
their child in at night
kissing them good night
I owe it to them to
experience it to the fullest
they
for whatever reason
they're not here and I am
sure I'm a mass by this point
[Laughter]
I have heard from so many people who've
been through some of the most horrific
things imaginable that we would all want
to avoid yeah and almost all of them
have said
they wouldn't have changed their thing
about their lives
would you have chosen to have a life
without any cancer
this sounds insane to people
but the greatest blessing God ever gave
me besides my children
was cancer
and I don't know how to reconcile that
but
it's changed my life in so many ways and
even if it were to come back and get me
the next time
I'm so grateful to have a second chance
to be here to wake up to drink coffee to
listen to birds
to fight traffic on the 101.
I wouldn't change it
the only thing I would want to change is
I didn't want that heartbreak for my
kids
that was hard on them
it's the only thing I would change
but you're more able to appreciate life
now
understatement of the imagery
life is
an Incredible Gift so
all the things that
you want to put off until tomorrow don't
because you you don't know and I was in
the prime
of my life and healthy and we had just
started building our dream house and
just everything in my life was perfect
a career
and then this
you just never know so so when you say
I'll do it later do it now when you say
well I don't want to do it because it's
hard do it anyway
you don't you don't know heck I could
leave here and get hit by a bus walking
back to my car
but I would know that
the last
six months since I've been off treatment
I've lived
even more than I already have
and I've said things to people
that maybe they find too forward or two
you know we live in a world of memes and
Snapchat and but now I'm just really
honest about how I feel about people and
if I miss someone I'll text them
randomly and say hey I miss you let's
spend time together let's do this I'll
text someone a random memory and I think
most people think oh I don't want to do
that I'll be a Clinger or I'll be weird
or I'll be overly sentimental
I plan to leave this earth with nothing
unspoken
and and one of the hardest things that I
did
during my treatment you know people ask
me would you rather have a slow death
or a quick death and not know and I said
oh no slow a slow
because I was able to to write my kids
letters and
make videos and
you know I wrote my
my boys are still young
my girls are grown up but
I wrote my boys letters for like
their High School graduation
their wedding
I planned
what I would put on my husband's
match.com profile because I I didn't
want him to be alone
but the rest of his life
um
because he wouldn't do it you know
and I got to to do a lot of
tying up Loose Ends
that thankfully I didn't need to but
there's something to be said about
having the opportunity to do it
instead of just being snuffed out in a
minute and like leaving so many things
left unsaid
what do you think most
people who have not been through the
things you've been through
don't realize about
their day-to-day lives
or just how they're how they're going
through life
I feel like people
get caught up in the everyday annoyances
of life and that weighs you down
it changed me as far as
if I go to my favorite restaurant and
it's closed for whatever reason you know
I get to try out something down the
street I haven't tried out I think you
know would probably annoy most people
for me it's an opportunity traffic
never-ending traffic in Los Angeles
to me I just get to jam out in my car
and dance and be stupid and have other
angelenos look at me like I'm a [ __ ]
um
Little Things
just little things and I would say
if there's a way that you can find the
silver lining in something just find it
it's it's sometimes it's hard because
you're annoyed as [ __ ] and I get that
I try to find the silver lining because
there is one there
and my silver lining was yes
I had cancer
I'm still technically stage three Ned
which means no evidence of disease but
I'm still stage three
because they don't know they won't know
until it pops up in an organ that I'm
staged for
so it's possible there's no cancer
there's possible there's cancer but it
just hasn't popped up in an organ so
I choose to just live
as if I'm completely
good to go and I'm completely healthy
and fine
until that scan shows that I'm not
and then I'll deal with it
My Silver Lining is
yes it was stage three
yes it was 18 months of treatment yes it
was terrible
sick I was sick as [ __ ] but it wasn't
stage four
wasn't stage four and that's all that
matters to me right now and the things
people don't tell you about cancer
treatment
you think you know
and my cancer twin my friend Leanne she
she was a marine and we had cancer
treatment at the same time on the same
day every month every three weeks we'd
have treatment
and she told me
they don't tell you these things she
said you'll have massive bowel problems
you'll get hives you'll be sick you'll
have heartburn they don't tell you any
of these things they tell you like in
the Pharma ads all the side effects
right
they don't tell you really how sick
you're gonna be
and that it really I felt far more sick
from the treatment than I ever did the
cancer
and you don't know
until you go through it
[Music]
it's changed the most in you is it your
ability to be honest with everyone
around you
[Music]
not so politically correct Maybe
I've never been politically correct
um I'm very in your face about stuff uh
but
I'm just very candid candid with love
um
I I would say what's changed is
[Music]
there's just no tomorrow
there's never a tomorrow
so if I want to do something I'm just
going to do it
that's it
and I wish that's how everybody could
live and I know it's not possible for
everybody
but I I
towards the end of my treatment I I've
always been a volunteer EMT well for a
few years now and I
I joined the local department when I
started to feel a little bit better
toward the end of treatment I joined the
local Department as an EMT and I
remember my Chief came to me and said we
really need people to go to fire school
and I said well
I'm not going to fire school I'm 41. I'm
not
and he said no no we really need people
to go and what he meant is you're going
to fire School young lady is what he
meant and I went
and I was two months out of treatment
and I went and
I'm a volunteer firefighter now and it's
like stuff that I probably wouldn't have
done before but
[ __ ] it you have one life
and why not
it's the weirdest craziest thing like
it's weird and nobody at the department
knows I'm an actress or whatever I have
a different legal name than I do in Sag
right and sagafter so no like nobody
knows and it's fine because I'm not
there for that but [ __ ] like that I
never would have done
they would have said go in that go fight
that vehicle fire go
now
no
no
new lease
[Music]
wonderful talk thank you so much
Jennifer
thank you
good luck from here on out
I don't need luck
I got God
thank you very much thank you